this is a production of cornell
university
so thank you so much for the
introduction and thank
you everyone for joining this
horticulture
section seminar i'll be talking today
mostly about
uh soil and not so much about plants i
will have
a small section about uh root exudates
uh toward the ends of the
of the presentation so right to it i'll
speak
shortly about my phd work in which i
uh study basically organomineral
interactions within a polymeric clay
type of system uh then i'll discuss some
a couple of projects that i've been
doing
in the lehman lab looking at soil
abiotic conditions and how they affect
carbon cycling
uh mostly focusing on soil water content
and some
aspects of neurology and then i'll
discuss some experimental plans and
setups that we have
for studying the role of root exudates
in the rise of your father
so uh as don said i'm a soil scientist
but uh strangely maybe my my phd
focused not so much on soil science but
on a functionalizing
clay minerals to be used as sorbents
to remove contaminants from water so our
working hypothesis was that
if we take smectite our typical
two-to-one
alkali mineral which is already a high
surface area
particle and is a pretty good sorbent
for inorganic cations
and we functionalize it with different
polymers that have different properties
in chemistries
we can then achieve really great removal
of a slew of organic
contaminants that are detected in
wastewater and different surface waters
and also that we can include some cool
designs and functions on this sorbent
such as
catalyzing the destruction of absorbed
pollutants on the surface and releasing
them as
less harmless by-products
and so just a short example of how this
looked like in one of these projects we
showed that
if we change the chemistry of the
solution of the polymer
we can induce changes
uh in the way the clay mineral and the
polymer chains
interact so basically organomineral
interactions but on a clay polymer
and so we transition from uh let me
go to laser
so we went from this uh flat uh
polymer configuration on the clay which
we call the trains configuration
into a more extended loopy configuration
that we call the loops and tails
type of configuration and of course this
means that there are more monomers
dangling into solution and that had
implications for how this material
was absorbing and interacting with other
organic pollutants
in the solution so
this was my last year of my phd i was
thinking about
doing a postdoc but at that time i was
mostly reading papers
in the field of material engineering and
research
and water treatment engineering
etc but i was still in the soil and
water department when this
article basically by mistake landed on
my desk
uh this hugely cited 2015 paper by
johannes lemon
from the soil crop section and marcus
claibor from organic state university
and in this paper and so just to say
that i was pretty much out of touch
from the soil science literature at that
time but in this paper
they synthesized recent data that called
for
a change in the paradigm of how we
think of a solar organic matter and so
in the
more conventional older
approaches the focus was on substrate
chemistry
that is the decomposition of organic
matter was seen as mostly a function of
the chemistry of the organic matter
so different hypotheses would put
forward and tested such as
dehumidification
hypothesis selective preservation of
recalcitrant materials progressively
composition etc
but these hypotheses were somehow
missing the fact that all of this was
happening in a soil matrix
whereas in this paper the framework that
was put forward and suggested
was that organic inputs from plants and
animals
were continuously being processed by
decomposer communities into smaller and
smaller compounds
which are becoming more and more
oxidized and
as these compounds were becoming more
smaller and more oxidized they
their affinity to interact with mineral
surfaces
or to go into soil aggregates increased
and so this organometal interactions in
aggregates or on mineral surfaces
decreased their availability to the
decomposer community
and all of these arrows are a function
of different abiotic and also biotic
parameters such as moisture temperature
biology
of the soil microbial community
and others so this this framework was
much more holistic taking into account
all of these different processes that go
into solar organic matter
dynamics and i thought wow how cool is
this
uh this is where i want to be especially
because organometer interactions were
such a large part of this
and i said let's go straight to the
source and was fortunate enough
to land a postdoc scholarship and work
with you
on this on this subject so another
fundamental understanding of this new
new framework was that
microbes in the soil not only are agents
of decomposition
of organic inputs in the soil but
they're also
they also constitute many times the
majority of
matter so for example in this paper
important
from paper from 2016 we see
the distribution of organic compounds
basically
in different classes on a clay mineral
that was
added that had glucose added to it
and then was incubated with a microbial
inoculum for 18 months
and then was analyzed again so this is
basically clay mineral
sugar microbes and the organic
composition is now
strikingly resembling that of a fuel
soil which indicates that
so organic matter must be mostly made
out of
organic of of microbes their macro their
necromancer and the microbial analytes
that they
exude throughout their lifetime a visual
piece of evidence for this is from an
image taken by
by johannes using a soft x-ray spectrum
sticks and hexafs and here we see a
microbial cell
in dark green surrounded by what is
probably
microbial metabolites and it's
interesting to see that these microbial
metabolites coat
the different soil mineral and black
particle black carbon particles in the
soil
so this just illustrates how soil
organic matter is
the product of microbial decomposition
of
organic inputs and the microbial
themselves and this
coating of microbial metabolites on salt
particles
is what we understand is the basis of
organomineral interactions
which protects soil organic matter from
further decomposition
and enable some of these compounds to
persistence
for decades and centuries
so after this uh very short intro i'll
uh show you some of the projects that
i've been working on focusing on
uh
so looking at water we know what the
immediate effects
are of water content on decomposition
so when we increase the amount of water
in the soil
there's an increased water activity and
a greater rate of diffusion
of nutrients and nutrients and
substrates due to the liquid
humidity and this is reflected in higher
sea loss here as transpiration and co2
but when we increase the water content
even further
oxygen diffusion now becomes a
a limiting factor sorry which is
reflected
in a decrease in color loss but although
the immediate
effect of water content is known the
long-term effect
of water content is less now and so
to try to probe this
this uh uh phenomenon we looked at
a an experimental plot close to krampus
on hatcher road
and this plot has been used and tested
for different bioenergy crops
as part of this campaign the soil water
content
has been uh
getting a chat here but for now um
has been uh measured many many times and
it's been established that there is a
moisture gradient
across this field so in the central part
of
these blue dots this area is relatively
wetter
than the outer regions of this field uh
which are relatively drier
so for each subplot was assigned a
sort of a normalized moisture value uh
dependent on a multi-annual
relative moisture calculation
so one of the uh observations from
previous work was that um with
increasing moisture values in the soil
there was an increase in organic carbon
and also of
total nitrogen and so we thought this is
a unique location to understand how
long-term oyster ingredient affects
uh this accumulation of carbon and try
to understand the mechanisms
underlying this accumulation
so we hypothesized that there could be
several different processes working
basically at the same time which could
affect what we're seeing
so with increasing soil moisture there
could be a
increase in the reductive dissolution of
mineral phases that are
redox sensitive uh when there is more
water there's
greater opportunity for element
transport vertical and
lateral with increased soil moisture up
to a certain point
there is an increase in microbial as we
just saw
uh soil organic carbon becomes more
oxidized due to this decomposition of
microbes
and then as organic compounds become
more oxidized
they generally become have
a higher affinity to absorb on soil
minerals because they become more
charged
and more likely to interact with
minerals
so these changes which hypothesized
are working across the mineral and the
organic components
of this uh this organometal interaction
idea uh we thought was probably
what was causing the differences in
the carbon content across the moisture
containers
and so we sampled a bunch of soils in
this
experimental plot and measured
several things try to understand this uh
we measured the microbial biomass
we did a density fractionation on the
soil which allows us to
isolate the articulate organic matter
pom which is the fraction that is most
resembling plant liter it's the least
composed
pool so the free pom is the pom that is
not within
aggregates the occluded pom is the purem
that is occluded inside aggregates
and we can also isolate the silt and
clay a heavy minimal fraction
and the mineral associated organic
matter maom
associated with that fraction we
extracted
soil oxides and hydrogen hydroxides
with a sequential extraction scheme and
we measured the
concentrations of aluminum iron and
carbon that are stored
inside each of these oxide pools and we
also perform soil incubations
to measure how much co2 is being
inspired from these different soils and
whether they relate to
uh soil properties
so today i'll discuss a little bit about
the microbial biomass the silicon clay
fraction
the oxide the soil oxide pool and
some of the results
so first of all we did a sequential
oxide extraction
in which we extracted increasingly
crystalline phases
of the soil and i'll walk you through
these results
so as a function of normalized moisture
values we have the extractable aluminum
extractable iron an extractable carbon
concentrations in the different extracts
we don't have to think now about what
colors which
the aluminum concentration was basically
constant across
the different normalized moisture values
and this is because aluminum phases are
usually
not moisture sensitive and not redox
sensitive
iron phases usually are or some of them
are
and we saw that the more non-crystalline
amorphous phases
decreased in their concentration in the
wetter soils
and the crystalline phases the more
ordered
minerals increased with increased
moisture
and this has been reported in the
literature and the explanation is that
wetter soils experience more
events of reducing conditions in which
iron is reduced dissolved
into solution and then when soils
re-dry again some of that iron
crystallizes
into a more a crystalline and orderly
type of
phase so this is explained by that and
then the carbon concentration across
moisture largely follow the patterns of
iron speciation so with the wetter soils
had more
carbon released from the crystalline
phases
and less carbon
you released that moisture had a pretty
substantial effect on iron speciation
and how much
carbon was being stored in each type of
phase
uh correspondingly and then we plotted
the carbon
against the iron and against the
aluminum extracted from each one of the
extractions to try to understand
which of these elements was more
important and so the non-significant
regressions
uh with iron but the significant
regression
regressions with the amorphous
aluminum phases show us that it was the
aluminum
um amorphous and organometal complexes
between carbon and aluminum uh were the
ones that were driving
storage of carbon uh in these soil oxide
pools and this also has been
increasingly been shown in recent
literature
looking at how moisture is affecting
oxide interactions with carbon
and then we are now looking at some
aspects of
microbial processing and cycling of the
soil organic carbon
so this is the carbon to nitrogen ratio
of the mineral associated organic matter
fraction
so the carbon nitrogen ratio decreases
with increasing moisture and then the
microbial biomass
normalized to sodium carbonate increased
with increasing moisture and the
dissolved organic carbon just a
dissolved carbon
substrate in the solution that also
decreased with increasing moisture
so how can the how can this be explained
so
higher moisture supported
the support of the higher microbial
biomass and more microbial
activity and the wetter soils this
probably led to
perhaps more uptake of dissolved
organic substrates and the increased
microbial processing of these substrates
with a larger
microbial biomass led to the deposition
of organic matter on the silt silken
clay fraction
that was more highly processed and more
microbial and signature
therefore had a lower carbon dimensional
ratio
so it's so we see that whether soils had
more microbes more microbial activity
and a mineral
associated organic matter fraction that
was more
microbially processed and then we did
ftir spectroscopy to look at how these
changes
in processing of carbon uh reflected on
the chemistry of the carbon
and so we have the three spectra are
averages
of soils from high mid and low
moisture levels and when the absorbance
of the peak is higher that means there
is more of that
functional group in this specific wave
number in the soil
so we'll go from from left to right in
the wetter soils we had more
o-h so more more phenolic groups and
more perhaps
we had more aliphatic carbon and we had
more
carboxylate and aromatic carbon and also
a relative increase in aromatic carbon
nitrogen
carbon nitrogen bonds and nh bonds
um and most of these are usually
assigned to
organic matter that is more microbial or
more
nature and while fdi is a great sort of
exploratory type of analysis that allows
us to understand
maybe differences that are happening in
the composition it is
it is difficult to obtain quantitative
numbers from this type of analytical
so we turn to carbon nmr on the right
and carbon neck saps which is another
type of spectroscopy that we
use for carbon and we looked at the rate
or sorry the ratio of carboxylic carbon
to aromatic carbon uh
in the maom fraction the silica fraction
of soils from low
mid and high moisture levels so this
ratio
again reflects the extent of
usually the decomposition of plant
matter into
microbial carbon
so we see that with increasing moisture
the ratio of carboxylic carbon to
aromatic carbon increased and that is
shown with carbon nmr
and carbon dioxides which means that in
wetter soils we had
more decomposition and the organic
matter was more microbial
in nature and less and that corresponded
with
decreasing carbon and nitrogen ratio so
all in all
wetter soils had more microbes
more processing of organic carbon and
that carbon was more oxidized
and then to try to relate the different
variables that we measured in soil
some of these i discussed and some i
didn't with
three important parameters one of them
is soil organic carbon
the contents of the carbon
mineralization which is the result
of what we find in the amount of co2
that's released from the soil
and mineralizability which is that co2
normalized
per unit carbon which reflects the
persistence of that soil organic carbon
it's its resistance to decomposition
uh so we have a correlation heat map
here and also to try to find
uh groups or sets of variables that best
explain
these three parameters reconstructed
several
partially square regression models and
these models are great for dealing with
data where we have less observations
variables
and variables that are very
multi-co-linear
so i've highlighted highlighted only the
predictors that
uh had a significant coefficients
so solar organic carbon stocks were best
explained by
mineral protection and exchangeable
calcium and amorphous
aluminum phases and by the amount of
litter
in fpon in the soil soil again and
carbon mineralization was basically a
function of carbon
and so organic carbon persistence was
linked to
a combination of microbial residues
here portrayed as the carbon nitrogen
ratio
and um protection by reactive iron and
aluminum phases
here the aluminum
this first project we saw that the
capacity of the soil to
accumulate and store carbon was a
combination
of microbial decomposition
of fan pinpoint and the soil mineral
phase capacity
to absorb and store these
by-products so moving on to the next
project
here we specifically wanted to look at
the role of
calcium uh in this story and this has
been
a focus in in the community for
us some recent years here
in a biogeochemistry review from 2018 by
mike
rowley uh shown that as soil ph
increases the relative
importance of aluminum and iron phases
in storing and stabilizing
carbon decreases whereas that of of
calcium
increases and this is just because of
how
soil chemistry
is transitioned across across
um and so these uh interactions with
calcium can be
uh in the uh form of
direct absorption to calcium carbonate
interactions with calcium ions that are
themselves absorbed on clays uh
aggregation and fluctuation and physical
protection
that is mediated by calcium others
and so in soils that are neutral or
slightly alkaline
in which calcium plays an important role
we often see that
with the more calcium we have
the more organic matter content that we
have
so we wanted to further explore this
this
relationship and try to try to find
specifically
somewhere
and so other studies have also shown
that other mechanisms
may exist so for example in this
incubation
of a organic horizon in which
soil minerals are largely absent the
addition of calcium
resulted in decreased hearing in black
in decreased mineralization of the
organic carbon
so because there are no minerals here
organomineral interactions probably play
a very small part of what is going on
here so
perhaps there are some organo-organic
interactions
in which uh calcium is um
and here this is data from that
buckley's lab uh
unpublished i think uh shows
that addition of calcium here in the
form
of addition of climbing drives a shift
in the microbial community in soil
and that shift is also associated with
a decrease decrease in the activity of
some
degradative enzymes and respiration
so we see that overall calcium may have
uh very different roles and additional
roles
um in addition to just organometallic
interactions and these women are
very
and so the experimental setup was was
the following
we took a soil and we pre-incubated it
with calcium chloride that was
enriched with the 44 isotope
and during this pre-incubation we caused
a 10 increase in exchangeable calcium so
some of this uh labeled calcium
went into the mineral matrix and kicked
off some
some other cations and then we leached
the soil of
excess salts and of course we did this
with control soil but without calcium
we air dry the soils and then we added
a 13c 15n uh leaf litter from willows
and we incubated this litter soil
mixture at
40 and 60 of their water holding
capacity
to continue our
interest in looking at how water content
is affecting all of this
on top of the role of calcium and this
incubation was
carried until uh 50
of the plant leader was mineralized
approximately and throughout the
incubation we measured co2
we also have some delta 13 cc2
measurements
uh we sampled the incubation at the
beginning and end of the incubation
and we isolated different fractions that
i also
showed in the previous project and
measured
carbon and nitrogen percentages
and isotope ratios to try to follow this
labeled litter tracer into the different
pools and we also sent out samples
for carbon and calcium next samps
we did fdi microscopy to try to get some
a spatial distribution of
minerals and organic matter
across these samples and we are also
hopeful to get some nanosims
uh images in the summer so nanosims is
basically a type of scanning electron
microscopy
microscope that can also identify and
measure the relative abundance of
different
elements so we can hopefully
locate where the labeled calcium is in
relation to
labeled carbon and nitrogen native
carbon and nitrogen and other sodium
minerals based on this
spatial distribution of these elements
try to understand
further the mechanisms underlying
what calcium is doing which is what i'll
be showing now so this is the cumulative
mineralization
and concealed carbon programmed soil
across the
patient so we have the low water content
treatment
the high water content treatment we have
the soils without
glitter and with litter and for each one
of these curves we have
a control dw
and a calcium treated soil what we can
see first is
in all of these combinations
except for the no litter high water
content calcium caused a decrease
in the co2 emitted so some sort of
stabilization was occurring
when we added this into the soils
at the beginning of the incubation at
day four so i forgot to say we
destructively sampled the day four and
then
day one hundred and third day four
around eighty percent of the co2
originated from litter carbon so the
microbes were busy
hacking away at the litter decomposing
it and some of that co2 was being
released
this was similar across the different
experimental conditions uh towards
the end of the incubation less of that
co2
was from the litter and more of it was
from the soil
carbon but there was also a difference
between different treatments
so in the low water content treatment
now
only 65 of the co2 was originating from
litter
whereas in the high water content uh
treatment
70 to 75 percent of the co2 originated
from jupiter
so we can say here that high water
content treatment
favored the utilization of litter as a
substrate
relative to the low water and
looking into further detail we can also
look at the amount
of pom in the free and occluded pools
with the different water contents so we
can see that the high water content
uh treatment increased fpo and
decomposition because
of this difference in the end time point
of the fpom content whereas
low water content increased the
decomposition of opiom
here again this difference between these
two uh these two box plots
signifying the amount of ovum at the end
of the experiment
and so you can see that water content
not only drove
uh litter decomposition but it also
affected
where that litter in the soil was being
decomposed
and to try to explain that we can we can
look at this
uh scheme of the soil matrix and let's
imagine for a second that
this is a vpom article that is in the
inter-aggregate
space not confined by by clay minerals
uh
the pore space the pore sorry the the
pore size diameter in these
in these spaces is usually is usually
quite large and
under a low water content treatment the
water here will
mostly be drained away and there will
likely not be enough
water to enable good decomposition of
fpom which is why
it's positions
whereas if we imagine this is an
included
pure and particle that's confined within
these clean minerals
uh the plus size diameter of these
locations is usually
much smaller and they can retain water
even at
red
looking now at the cycling of litter
into the microbial biomass we find some
some interesting
things so under calcium treatment at the
beginning accumulation
we find that the fraction of microbial
biomass carbon
from litter increased relative to
control soils this was highly evident at
the beginning of the incubation
and slightly less sometimes the energy
is still significant
so we added calcium and more litter
was being incorporated into microbial
biomass carbonate
and this was uh also associated with
higher economies efficiency
under calcium treatment so we added
calcium
and purging carbon of litter more carbon
was being assimilated and turned into
microbial biomass
then co2 then carbon lost as co2
in the calcium treatment again very
evident at the beginning of the
experiment and
somewhat less so towards the end of the
experiment so we see here that
calcium favored the efficient
inoperation
of the litter carbon into microbial
biomass carbon and we know that this
is the pathway towards
stabilized carbon
and now looking at the litter carbon
that is
uh that has found its way after being
processed
into the cervical refraction we thought
that
calcium would drive this upwards
but counter-intuitively we found the
opposite
so calcium treatment caused
a lower percentage of carbon
in the maom pool to originate from the
label
relative to the control dw soils
at the beginning of the incubation at
the end of the incubation this sort of
evened out
and in the low water content we still
saw this
difference so at the beginning less
carbon from the label
reached a certain clear fraction
probably because more of it was still
being cycled through the mental health
and then looking at the c to n ratio of
the label
on the silt and clay fraction so at the
beginning of the experiment there was
not a lot of differences or mixed
differences
across the watercolor treatments but
then at the end of the incubation
after a lot of this processing has
already occurred
we can see that cdn ratio of the soils
treated with calcium
was significantly lower than in soils
not treated with calcium so this shows
that
although carbon from the label did not
immediately reach the silicon clay it
first stopped i guess at the microbial
biomass when it was
finally deposited on certain clay
particles it was more highly processed
perhaps containing microbial
necromancers and microbial
metabolites with lower c to n ratios
those were being deposited on
so to try to put all of these different
findings together into a
mechanism-like scheme
we saw that plant litter was being
incorporated into the fao
fpom or the op1 pools the relative
contribution of these
is likely controlled by aggregation of
this elevation
though this is not something that we
looked at this
specific product we saw the high
moisture
favor the decomposition of vpom while
low moisture
favored the decomposition of
uh soils treated with calcium
uh had a higher incorporation of
decomposed litter
into the microbial biomass and
preferentially more deposition of highly
processed
microbial necromancers and probably
extracellular metabolites
on the certain clay or ma1 infection
uh whereas the control soils
had relatively more deposition of
partly decomposed litter um on the
certain preference
and putting everything together this
resulted in
higher carbon to nitrogen ratio on the
maom
lower carbonyl's efficiency more co2
emitted
in the control soils and lower carbon to
nitrogen ratio
higher carbon use efficiency and less
co2 emitted
when we treated the soils with a calcium
salt
so moving forward and i hope that i'm
pretty much on time
i'll share some experimental plans that
we have for studying the role of root
oxidase
carbon unfortunately i don't have a lot
of results but i do have some
cool image and some interesting plans
so several studies
have tried to quantify
root oxidation and it is said that
anywhere between
three and eleven percent of the carbon
that plants fix
are allocated or lost depends on how you
look at it
as root exudates so a substantial amount
of carbon
entering the soil is in the form of
velocities
at the same time we also think that
the injection of soluble good oxidative
compounds
into the rhizosphere which is highly
populated by microbes is
um has a higher chance of
resulting in carbon that is microbially
processed
and therefore can persist long term in
the soil
relative to above ground plant litter
that is sometimes deposited
on areas that do not necessarily have
a high microbial population
so this point of entry and solubility of
oxides make
this uh carbon pool mood exudates
very interesting in the point of view of
a soil scientist
looking at the solar carbon dynamics
another thing is composition so this is
a
metabolite profiling of a risosphere
soil and a bulk soil
in a base field so you see that
because of excavation and other other
root processes
uh the composition of the soil solution
is vastly different the rhizosphere soil
versus the bulk soil so this combination
of
different chemical composition the
solubility of the compounds versus
solid compounds the high density of
decomposers and intimate
interaction with
soil minerals makes devices fear sort of
the most interesting piece to be
right now for studying solution
and think again thinking again about a
certain abiotic conditions and
specifically water content
uh it's been shown that drought uh can
cause a change
in the composition of root excavates so
here
in a normal treatment eighty percent of
exudates were primary metabolites
uh and here seventy percent of the
seventy percent of the exudates
uh were secondary metabolites when these
cancers were
subjected to the drug treatment in
another paper
shown here drought-induced exhibition
where these exudates were then collected
and
put into another soil that did not
experience this
drought that resulted in increased soil
organic carbon mineralization
so you see that again abiotic conditions
can result indirectly
in differences in solar organic
chromosomes
there are many unknowns across this
interface
of vent roots uh soil and carbon
so for example while in our
in the in the previous project we showed
how soil available conditions can
regulate
a litter turnover this information is
largely missing
we don't really understand the mechanism
underlying
higher mineralization with
drought-induced
excitation we would like to know more
about which compounds or compound
classes are involved in drought-induced
mineralization
all of these all of these questions are
embedded in the research plans that we
have so to try to understand this
um this role of roots and root excavates
and
carbon cycle we've thought of
several methods and some experimental
setups
so the first is this microcosm which we
have designed
in which uh the co2
um respires from the soil is trapped
within this headspace
and that headspace is isolated from the
rest of the atmosphere
so that we can measure the
soil co2 respiration without it being
mixed with
the error atmosphere so for example if
we take a see-through soil or a soil
that has
mostly vegetation and grow c4
plants such as such as maize so using a
isotopic mixing model we can calculate
the amount of excitates
and we can partition those oxidates as
they go
into co2 and different soil and
microbial pools and try to understand
uh their turnover under different
conditions and then to
try to probe the composition of the
rhizosphere solution
as roots grow and compare it with bulk
soil
we are going to use microdialysis probes
which are basically
these tiny tubes that have a semi
semi-permeable membrane and we we pump a
solution through this tubing usually
just water or
some salt uh
solution and as as the solution flows
the solution in the soil uh diffuses or
some of these
uh solutes diffuse into the membrane
then we continue
to probe and collect the solution
with minimal interference and then to
try to
locate the probe in relation to the
roots
we can use a microct so this is an image
taken
here at the biotech institute the
emerging facilities
so this is a soil core like you saw
before the
acrylic tube and here we can see that
the tubing and the micro dialysis
these white specks are coarse grains
inside the soil
and we are also now looking at how we
can identify the roots so we can
um as a function of the density of the
roots or the proximity of the roots to
the microderosis probe
we can now try to relate the composition
of compounds in the rhizosphere
to the proximity of the roots so those
are the questions that are
now being asked by us and so that
with that i will finish up thank you so
much for
for uh giving me your time and listening
i'd like to thank
the different research groups that i
have
uh had the opportunity to work with uh
different analytical and service labs
and some funding agencies
and with that i'm very happy to take all
right
thank you so much let me ask
if there are questions from the group
for
itamar and if you have a question
uh just unmute yourself
i am not seeing any questions
so itar i will ask one which
is in your experimental work either
previously with johannes layman or
currently with taran barely
have you looked across a spectrum of
soil types clays loams sandy soils
uh to determine how the organic
fraction behaves
yeah so in a in another project that i
did not discuss at all here we have
a collection which we call the national
soil collection
uh mostly collected by rachel acqua a
phd student in
where we have uh soils from
70 or 80 different locations in the
united states
so we are exploring many different
relationships between soil organic
carbon
pools and cycling and trying to relate
those to many different
variables that we that we see in the
soil so yes
the short answer is yes thank you
uh other questions from the group let's
see i'm not
seeing any so i want to thank you itamar
for
that very well done um
seminar and uh along with that i want to
wish everyone a happy end of the
semester
and summer in that this wraps up
our seminars for spring 21
as well as i should mention my eight
years
of running this seminar so thank you all
bye bye now thank you bye-bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu